[Música]
en primera plana
braulio moro
[Música]
bienvenidos a en primera plana una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con france24 en español
dedicada al análisis de la situación
internacional situación que hoy nos
lleva a cuba donde se han producido el
estallido social más importante en los
últimos 30 años que sorprendió al
gobierno y también a la comunidad
internacional pues prueba que hay una
crisis generalizada en la isla del
caribe hubo una crisis final una crisis
total estamos en primera plana
[Música]
para hablar de lo que está sucediendo en
la más grande de las islas del caribe
tenemos con nosotros a nuestros
invitados
stefan wittke investigadores del
instituto de altos estudios para américa
latina bienvenido stefan clases del
cantautor aquí delia arantegui
periodista independiente especialista en
economía bienvenida del día general y a
distancia saludamos armando valdés
zamora catedrático de la universidad
parís este reto y bienvenido armando un
placer estar aquí como usted cree
hablando de cuba que es un tema de
actualidad pero al cual a veces tenemos
dificultad de acceder
a los medios y es bueno en este momento
hay que aprovechar la coyuntura que hace
a la cultura trágica por el polvo ah
pues bienvenido una vez más armando aquí
tendrás oportunidad evidentemente de
expresar su punto de vista vamos a ver
lo que dice la prensa internacional al
respecto de esta situación crítica que
se está viviendo en cuba para ello
abrimos con el periódico oficial del
partido comunista cubano granma que en
su edición del 12 de julio es decir un
día después de las protestas el título
nosotros no vamos a entregar la
soberanía ni la independencia del pueblo
ni la libertad de esta nación es decir
retomaba las declaraciones del
presidente díaz canel en la vecina miami
en eeuu donde vive una importante
comunidad de origen cubano el nuevo
herald
hacía referencia a las denuncias de
desaparecidos en todas las provincias
por causa de la represión y finalmente
el sitio digital cubanet opuesto al
régimen escribió turistas es hora de
saber por qué protestamos en cuba
stefan la gran mayoría de los analistas
afirma o inciden en que las protestas de
aguas son inéditas no sólo por su
magnitud tocaron más de 40 ciudades sino
por la fuerza que esto ha llevado por la
cantidad de gente que se movilizó
pareciera que tomó por sorpresa al
gobierno de cuba es difícil decir si los
gobiernos estaba totalmente sorpresa por
los eventos imagino que si la forma que
tú ves y tal vez alguna consecuencia es
que el gobierno pienso pero en 2019 el
presidente y el escáner anuncio
decisiones muy difícil para el país
entonces todo es totalmente
una sorpresa pero me parece que las
consecuencias de la unificación
monetaria a partir del primero de enero
tuvieron consecuencias concretas
sociales un descontento importante en el
país una insatisfacción real es una
realidad una crisis económica social
bastante grave de grave de más de tres
años más o menos las consecuencias de la
corrida de las cuerdas del turismo sabe
que había cuatro millones de turistas en
2019 un millón en el año pasado para el
primer trimestre sólo 60 mil turistas
entonces quien el turismo queda también
de de las consecuencias de las remesas
consecuencias también de las relaciones
las cuales han perdido en las medidas
decidió desde el bloqueo y también
también hay un contexto internacional
particularmente pero yo diría que hay
una campaña que no podríamos totalmente
descartar la idea y aquí realmente
una publicidad una campaña mediática y
política violenta y más sobre cómo decir
más como decir más indirecta y violenta
porque realmente ese respeto entonces
como saben hay atentos violentos con las
bajadas realidad con la baja del caso
cuando desde el club en washington y en
bani martes en parís con los cócteles
molotov muchos actos de vandalismo que
son cosa con que el recurso lo evento
entonces cuando se ve es un evento
inédito 94 fue un momento muy importante
de crisis importante y luego en otros
los balseros y aquí el tiempo hay una
diferencia importante hay dos cosas
definir distintas el primero el gobierno
es totalmente diferente vamos hablar
sobre esa misma gente si bien es el
miedo históricos y el segundo viento muy
importantes el internet
bien a partir de 2008 y cambia
totalmente
los parámetros estos son los temas que
vamos a abordar precisamente muchas
gracias
armando recuerdo que ustedes nos
acompañan a distancia en las protestas
participaron jóvenes pero no sólo
también vimos en las imágenes gente de
todas las edades esto cambia un poco la
idea de lo que se puede ver con respecto
a cuba la que se tendría de cuba porque
generalmente tiende uno a pensar que las
personas de más edad mantienen un cierto
apego a lo que se considera la evidencia
de esa revolución interno se presenta
algo que nadie se esperaba y por qué son
las clases populares qué pasa que esto
no es un movimiento ni de izquierda ni
de derecha ni de jóvenes ni de viejos un
movimiento general en realidad
las personas mayores y cuba como en
todas partes son conservadoras y va a
ser conservador quiere hacer tener miedo
al cambio en este caso porque tienen una
protección mínima que ha ido
desapareciendo después de comer unos
kilos de arroz al mes es decir que decir
que la educación y la salud en este caso
la salud para ellos
y estas cosas pero todo se ve perdido
porque están viendo a sus hijos están
viendo a sus nietos cómo están creciendo
y entonces una de las imágenes icónicas
además de este movimiento es una señora
mayor que hablo en twitter con una
caldera como se hace en américa latina
tradicionalmente yo creo que ahí está la
clave de todo bien por ahí pues tiene
que comenzar
es decir la maldición entre otra entre
comillas está que teníamos desde hace
una excepción que la gente no se tira a
la calle no ya somos como los
nicaragüenses ya somos como los
colombianos ya somos como los los
chilenos es decir ya somos como los
bolivianos esto no es de izquierdas ni
derechas ni de jóvenes ni viejo porque
master press ahora que fueron fieles al
régimen son las que peor viven porque 35
por ciento de los cubanos vida del
dinero del exilio
delia apropósito lo que nos señala
armando precisamente es un dato
interesante 35 por ciento de los cubanos
viven del dinero del exilio pero el
problema es que las remesas se han caído
al gobierno de cuba entre otras cosas
exactamente y eso es lo que ha creado
también un descontento generalizado
porque al decir que estas personas viven
de estas remesas es literal es para
comprar productos de alimenticios para
el día al día al no contar con esta con
esta entrada estamos hablando de una
población que está viviendo
prácticamente de nada haciendo colas
para comprar un kilo de arroz o para
tener las raciones que se han sido
disminuidas por la crisis y por el
problema que en cuba en este momento
tienen problemas de liquidez en dólares
y no pueden comprar las importaciones
los productos importados de primera
necesidad estamos hablando realmente de
alimentos como él
leche carne es decir todos estos
productos de primera necesidad
hay penuria en cuba y por eso es que
vemos la clase popular saliendo a las
calles porque no es una cuestión por
supuesto está la cuestión de los jóvenes
la libertad pero también hay una
cuestión de necesidad básica de
alimentación y las medidas que ha tomado
el gobierno de eeuu pero previamente la
administración trump son muy duras
pienso yo porque afectan directamente a
las personas de a pie sí sí sí o sabemos
decir ese término porque les quitan toda
capacidad de mantenerse y eso lo podemos
ver en las protestas son personas de
clase obrera de clase que van a
protestar porque no tienen
desafortunamente que comer un dato que
es importante que ustedes tengan en
cuenta que es que en 2019 el apagón del
año pasado en 2020 el producto interno
bruto de curva cayó 11 por ciento 11 por
ciento se derrumbó el producto interno
bruto y como señalaba este
el problema es que con el coronavirus
con la baja del turismo los ingresos que
estaba recibiendo la población se han
caído la margen de maniobra y además hay
que agregar otra cosa que es por ejemplo
el problema de los cortes eléctricos que
también son los más prolongados desde la
crisis de los años 90
de un problema que no tiene visión a
resolver entonces yo creo que es por eso
también que estas protestas han tomado
esa magnitud y como el cambio de la
moneda es decir la eliminación de una de
las moderadas
corrientes la que tenía la misma paridad
con el dólar ha generado una inflación
el gobierno ha trate ha tratado de
paliar esto con el alza de los salarios
pero no se logra no se logra y la
inflación sigue y va a seguir aumentando
entonces yo creo que es también la
inestabilidad que se ha generado en la
isla lo que provoca este tipo de
protestas que no solamente se generan en
la habana sino en muchas otras ciudades
pequeñas ciudades en 40 de forma
simultánea lo que provoca también el
acceso a internet es la simultaneidad
algunas fuentes hablan incluso que no
sólo no sólo fueron 40 sino hasta 60
ciudades donde se habrían producido
estas protestas el día 11 y el día 12 de
julio aunque de manera más reducida
stefan la crisis económica lo vemos está
impactando de manera muy considerable a
toda la isla a la población de cuba
inciden las sanciones las famosas 243
medidas que la administración trump
aplicó en su momento y que sigue el
gobierno de joe biden como influye esto
en la isla región yo diría tres medidas
hay 242 medidas de enero
me parece dos lo más importante es el
primero es de reducir el número de
turistas americanos desgracias pérez
para para visitar cuba porque era una
fuente de ingresos para las cuenta
propistas que vivíamos desde este tipo
de turistas está una quedada muy
importante
el segundo punto es se dividen de manera
clara es las remesas que como decía las
remesas de la diáspora como americana
que realmente no pudieron entrar en el
tercero punto es la como decía el activo
de la ley extraterritorial la verdad es
una manera de conducir
e impedir a los inversionistas desde de
explorar y de visitar cuba esta fuente
el gobierno estaba esperando mucho de
las inversiones extranjeras que no puede
más participar
a los bancos extranjeros los de las
empresas no pueden participar al
desarrollo económico del país son
entonces consecuencias muy concretas
para el pueblo cubano y para algo
vengo por el jugo del día muy brevemente
un mes antes del estallido social del 10
de junio precisamente el gobierno
anunció que el banco central de cuba iba
a detener la recepción de divisas en
dólares el líquido que efectos ha tenido
esto para la población desestabilización
total porque no era algo esperado pero a
la vez las personas que reciben las
remesas a través de giros directos de
eeuu se encuentran en la duda porque
ahora las personas que puede desean
hacer un giro de moneda tienen que
cambiar a otra moneda euro yen pero no
va a poder ser de ahora en adelante en
dólares bien vamos a hacer una primera
pausa estamos llegando ya a la primera
parte de este debate sobre cuba volvemos
en unos instantes más aquí en primera
plana
[Música]
todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar de mujeres en ellos hoy hablamos
de nuestra diversidad nuestros logros y
nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
[Música]
el día soy en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
estamos de regreso ya aquí en primera
plana con nuestros invitados
stefan wittke investigador del instituto
de altos estudios para américa latina de
delia arrunátegui periodista
independiente especialista de economía y
también a distancia con armando valdez
catedrático de la universidad de parís
escrita a todos ustedes una vez más
gracias por acompañarnos stefan tras el
estallido del 11 de julio el presidente
díaz canel calificó los hechos de
simplemente disturbios no hablo de una
explosión social pero dijo algo que era
muy importante dijo ha dado la orden de
combatir está dada la orden de combatir
está dada una frase que nunca se había
escuchado ni siquiera las protestas de
1994 no porque es un poco diferente el
contexto es diferente y me parece que
miguel díaz-canel pronunció esta frase
de manera un poco yo imagino pero es una
interpretación totalmente personal que
se recuerda de los eventos del 94 cuando
los efectos de los balseros en agosto de
94 en el contexto del maleconazo en una
reconoce exactamente en período especial
entonces fidel vino personalmente para
hablar
y pidió a la policía que no siquiera
acerca y habló con la gente
personalmente habló habló habló imaginó
que la manera de hacer de participar al
evento de estar salir en las calles y
pedir el apoyo de del pueblo para
defender la revolución imagino que un
poco
es un poco eco a un poco al alza del
canal ahora imagino que es un poco lo
que estaba pensando y y tal vez fue un
poco sorpresa por la importancia de los
blogs del internet y en 2002 porque fue
una decisión personal de miguel
desgracias de abrir totalmente en
internet y yo pienso que tal vez no
pienso todas las consecuencias políticas
y porque como saben hay la agencias de
las agencias muy activas muy ligadas con
la silla y el aire
en el que es la fundación para la
democracia financia de manera
consecuente no las redes sociales los
blogs los internet los movimientos
algunos raperos artistas y fue bastante
bien organizado desde más de dos años y
me parece que el gobierno el presidente
miguel díaz canel tal vez su cese son
menores y no estimula totalmente las
consecuencias mueven las eficiencias de
este tipo de situación que yo pienso
vamos a ver lo que nos dice armando la
represión según la oposición dejó
cientos de detenidos y desaparecidos
cosa que el gobierno niega el presidente
de joe biden impulsó sanciones y dijo
que es sólo el comienzo
qué más puede hacer el presidente vaivén
con respecto al gobierno de cuba
sabiendo la cantidad de sanciones que ya
tiene sobre él ahí ahí está pero muy
interesante que es este juego de ping
pong desde ue voleibol entre entre cuba
el cubano el gobierno
y que no es lo mismo y los eeuu y en
parte por esto lo que pasa es que va a
ir en declara lector al principio para
decir al principio declara esto después
se echa para atrás
y dice que va a utilizar algunas medidas
como aumentan las remesas como aumentar
el personal a la embajada quienes bailen
bueno va a ir de gira el presidente
obama es declaró al principio que no iba
a ser a seguir la política coma que no
funcionado porque el régimen cubano se
fortaleció el recuerdo además que obama
el último día de su mandato que por
casualidad estaba en miami donde vive
una gran parte de mi familia de robo la
ley que no nos daba la residencia de
manera automática
las medidas van a ser medidas que
corresponden a su línea política a la
influencia que tiene el diputado los
representantes en congresos demócratas
sobre el que son medidas así es tratar
de mandar más ayuda en este sentido pero
pero no hay para nada está este fantasma
con el cual él construyó su fortaleza
sobre todo hacia el exterior el régimen
cubano de que somos las pequeñas
víctimas del imperio cuando el imperio
está el imperio le está comprando 250
300 millones de dólares al año en comida
pero bueno las medidas yo no creo que
sean van a ser cosméticas esto no se
arregla el problema y cuando es
económico el bromato es político del día
coincido con esta apreciación de armando
que el problema de cuba es político y no
económico es complicado separar lo
político de lo económico yo creo que son
dos factores que van de la mano porque
la economía tiene que tener una
correlación con la política y no se
puede separar decir que una cosa es
político y otro económico cuando es una
parte de un conjunto claramente a mi
entender hay un problema económico grave
en cuba' del sistema económico que no
está funcionando de forma correcta ya
que hay una dependencia
muy fuerte a las importaciones hay una
dependencia de las remesas es decir el
dinero que recibe de los cubanos de la
diáspora de otros países
hay un problema de liquidez ya que hay
una dolarización en la isla es decir y
al mismo tiempo hay un problema de
liquidez ya que no hay mucho no se puede
yo no estoy de acuerdo con separar las
cosas de la política con la agronomía yo
creo que tiene que haber una evolución
en la economía en el proyecto económico
que vaya que vaya en correlación a la
política para que siga habiendo una
coherencia en el discurso político pero
de misma de la misma forma que la
economía cambia ya que en este momento
es inviable que continúe como está ahora
la cuerda inicio a punto importante
stefan la población de cuba vive desde
hace más de 10 50 años en una especie de
sándwich por un lado muchos errores del
gobierno por otro lado las sanciones de
eeuu quiero evocar una frase de fidel
castro durante uno de sus últimos
discursos en la universidad de la habana
que me parece que vale la pena citar
dijo en aquel entonces en 2006 esta
revolución puede destruirse a sí misma y
sería nuestro error pareciera que no hay
espacio para el manejo de las
diferencias en cuba pareciera que boyle
puede destruirse desde el interior esta
situación esta revolución con lo que
queda de ella
y lúcida no es la visión de fidel
totalmente
parece evidente son parece que los
dirigentes cubanos son muy conscientes
de los inclusive de los errores y los
ministros reconocen sus errores y hay
muchos errores
tal vez económicas de la gestión de
cotidiana tal vez y por ejemplo de una
burocracia evidente hay una
el peso de las empresas públicas que no
son eficientes
errores también me parece en mi relación
como
es un tema más complicado con la
sociedad civil que está siendo
emancipando de más de 10 años hay
realmente
una situación un poco inédita pero
pienso que el gobierno cubano está un
poco
preparando el problema siguiente es como
decían perfectamente el político el
económico son totalmente ligados
entonces como entonces acelerar la de la
actualización del modelo económico
actual
y entonces que no está totalmente nada
de nada por el momento y continuar la
institucionalización de la revolución
una ecuación muy difícil sin fidel sin
raúl es el elegido teniendo falta la
legitimidad histórica de la revolución
de 59 días
nos dice armando recuerdo que nos sigue
a distancia qué medidas debería tomar el
gobierno para calmar esta situación a
sabiendas que hasta ahora se ha negado a
cualquier tipo de negociación con los
diversos sectores de la oposición
armando cuáles entonces lo que tiene que
hacer el gobierno con una cosa es lo que
debe hacer el gobierno cubano y otra lo
que va a hacer de acuerdo a su
trayectoria lo que debe hacer por
supuesto es un diálogo pero esa palabra
no existe en cuba a ver lo de las
personas que están viendo
yo conozco lo que ocurre en colombia de
un país que lleva adoro con el que
estaba reunido ayer por cierto con una
universidad
yo conozco lo que ocurrió en chile tengo
colegios chilenos yo conozco lo que ha
ocurrido en américa latina' bueno pero
está estaba ocurriendo en países donde
hay oposición que hay los problemas de
la democracia y canadá
pero el caso de los cubanos ustedes se
dan cuenta que no está prohibido tratar
de exponer una opinión contraria
entonces esto tiene que pasar con un
diálogo con la oposición interna para
que nos sigan diciendo que la mafia de
miami y que existe esa oposición y con
los representantes de esos que están
saliendo a la calle con un
reconocimiento de esa disparidad de
opinión
y con una preparación de una transición
pacífica esto está muy bonito esto lo
que quiere todo el mundo es todo lo que
sabemos por razones lógicas los que
vivimos en democracia que hay que hacer
pero ese no es el discurso del rey'
mengual por una sola razón si eso ocurre
si eso ocurre el partido comunista one
tiene menos de 15 por ciento en una
elección popular entonces eso no va a
ocurrir y eso es lo lamentable y lo que
hay que evitar aquí es una tragedia que
se está reproduciendo en los últimos
días con un poco menos de difusión por
cierto que es ese enfrentamiento hacia
el interior y eso es una explosión que
tiene que mediar la comunidad
internacional
esa transición ese diálogo hay que
hacerlo la comunidad internacional como
mediación como se dice en francés yo
peso mi palabra yo no hago la
intervención mediación del día de manera
muy muy breve posible una intervención
una mediación como lo sugiere armando es
posible hoy que el gobierno se pueda
regenerarse regenerar perdón en 30
segundos depende de que se para
adaptarse a la nueva situación que vive
la isla yo creo que en los los cambios
tienen que ser graduales para que no
sean un choque para la dgt para la gente
y que el gobierno sepa llevarlos de
forma gradual y adaptada a la realidad
actual con internet de por medio pues
muchas cosas en los que dan aquí en el
tintero efectivamente yo quisiera
recordar simplemente que cuba este año
cumple ya casi 60 años de bloqueo desde
los estados unidos hacia la isla y sobre
todo el próximo mes de agosto se
cumplirán 27 años de las movilizaciones
de lo que se conoce como el maleconazo
vamos a ver que lo cual es la situación
que se puede surgir de ahí hay una
situación bastante tensa todavía hoy en
la isla se nos quedan
en el tintero el problema de los
prisioneros cómo van a ser tratados el
problema si se les liberan o no la
presencia de la unión europea en fin en
todo caso estamos llegando ya al final
de esta en primera plana dedicada a la
crisis en cuba quiero agradecer a
nuestros invitados a delia arrunátegui
periodista independiente economista su
presencia de sus estudios gracias a
stefan wittke investigadores del
instituto de altos estudios para américa
latina gracias stefan y addis fans y
armando valdés zamora también el
habernos acompañado también le doy las
gracias a este maravilloso equipo que
está detrás de la consola que ustedes
una nueva cita aquí la próxima semana en
otra en primera plana
[Música]